CH I like this dude for the views oh my
just press this and then where did you
buy this at Amazon holy that's
up hold on it's going to hurt I know oh
my God Brian do it for the
camera mer chin this is Chin's idea chin
wants this let's
go okay you did it twice you want to try
you running at me I do it to your heart
do it to my heart right now
that's hurt CH I'm not even kidding it's
not worth it man no I'm not doing that
no you do it to him yeah do it to my
heart I'm not even joking it's not going
to do it's not going to do just try it I
feel like it's a bad idea kill him kill
CH this is really the fighter in the kid
come on baby I just want to say to
everybody that if I seem a little uh pey
in my step it's cuz I had some deer meat
Steven Rellis deer meat I had some mule
deer this morning Beres gave he gave you
someone uh he was here uhuh yeah he did
and I I've not gotten into my magic mind
yet but I'm afraid of what happens then
I'm afraid he makes elk berries magic
are you kidding me dude dude I turn into
a I turn into Pan the great Forest God
look up pan he's or don't right well pan
you might want to look up pan when I say
I'm pan you say pan or pan pan p and
yeah he's a forest God gets a lot of
nymphs pregnant and you'll see why go
ahead and bring him up um he's usually
got a yeah he's usually got a major he's
usually got a major boner so you're tur
to basically a gay Forest man well I
don't know how gay he is he's got horns
that guy is pretty gay oh this gu there
he is there he is there he is wow you
turn dude I need some berries and elk
meat stack well take go to that statue
right there go go to the go to one of
those statues all the way over there no
no no that one the other that one I
don't there you go he's got the high
quarters of a goat just big old balls
and a dong that's about the size of his
arm actually about size his leg what's
the size of his flute yeah and here he
is goat so he's a goat boy I don't know
if I want to do the deer meat anymore
well that's why they say he's a horny
old goat if you're an old man if you're
in your 50s and you're horny they call
you a goat he's a he's a horny old goat
and that's you and me I'm on the left
yeah
no wait you're the goat that no I'm on
the I'm the goat with the big hey what's
this he's oh that's a gay that's a gay
pan I told you he's gay no they're all
but look at that Tiny Dick and he's got
a big old heavy every picture shows that
he is a gay man in the forest so he's
banging goats and and Wayward dudes who
happen to be naked so you eat meat and
take magic mine and turn into
that um yeah now now what's funny is
that I was going to introduce our lovely
sinas tavol but I I need a bridge I need
we got to create some energy before that
I don't want to go right from that we
just do a seg like say what's the deal
you ever tried elk yeah there you go now
you don't like game ging meat no no I'm
I'm a strictly chicken and beef gal
chicken and beef not even fish so
conservative really no not a pescatarian
and you but you grew up where I grew up
in Orange county soas is Persian too
right yes and you have Persian no 100%
100% listen to her name 100% body 100%
my name literally means Persian princess
yes couldn't get more Persian and you
grew up um very common Persian name you
grew up eating kabi and all that you
know it so well yes I do yeah for sure
grew up eating a ton of Persian food you
Kidd me yes it's it's great I'm like
immune to the rice thing because of it
well I went to a Persian restaurant and
my friend said he goes man this is good
food and I said do you think they've
been around for 5,000 years do you think
that a civilization has been that round
got some food right I F it drives me
nuts when 5,000 years mean yeah working
in the shop oh this is good this here
Rocky food is good you mean Babylon yeah
[__] get it together sorry man I get
you know I get a little feisty it's the
it's the elk man you just want to hook
up with dudes get it no no no no I
didn't say that elk and berries man
you're trying to put your wiener in some
butt no no no I said I'm pan but I don't
I'm not into goats when I see a goat pan
is first of all I don't want to have sex
with goat an seexual well I don't want
to have sex with a goat where the goat's
facing me that's really decrepit you
just want to do it from the back you
always think of when people have sex
with a sheep or a goat you think the
goat's facing down I've never thought
about it Bri well you don't think the
goat is on it bring up pansexual cuz
that's what Brian is oh that's
interesting is sexual romantic or
emotional attraction toward people of
all genders see your pan regard of their
sex or gender identity the pansexual
force moner is that bisexual no dude oh
cuz now there's all trying to get canell
it's everything yeah you're just into
whatever goats fors leaves dudes dudes
no I think it's just dud dud no no
that's a dude sexual I'm not a dude
sexual bro when you think about it Peter
Pan yes pan sexual he's the boy who
never wants to grow up dud he yeah never
grow up and just fly around and tight
yeah and Tinkerbell is trying to [__]
the entire movie and he's just not into
it just want to hang out with the Lost
Boys figure it out people dude you're
right
Peter pan pan sex let's fire and just
get all Smokey and see what happens
smoke kills all the STDs I think that's
I don't know how that works I don't know
dude we do know you're pan I'm pan
sexual I'm really not but I wish I was
my wife has had uh this is all [__]
aside I'll call her right now my wife
has had in the past two days she's had
dreams that she's cheating on me that
she had sex well that means that means
she's thinking about it 100% yeah and is
it with a big black guy no it wasn't Dam
[__] she's not she's not sharing all
no it wasn't damn it um yes yeah well
well it was with guys who were um
Regular dudes one guy she was like I
can't I'm married and then she did
anyway and then she had sex with a
friend of hers that a longtime old
friend back in the day I think she had
sex with back in the day like in real
life or in the dream in real life and
she said she was putting her bra on I
walk in and she goes I just cheated on
you and I was like that's all right and
I W yeah and she said I went up to shake
hands with the guy and the guy grabbed
his [__] and ran out of the room and
then she spent the rest of the room
dream trying to find me cuz she's like I
think he's pissed at me I don't know she
know you're [__] yeah cuck yeah cuck you
can find me in the corner crouching the
like jacking it pan style I like that
she was like a cheat on you're like yeah
it's all right man old easy goinging Bri
old easygo Bri that pisses her
off no I don't think so because I wonder
if it pisses off that you just don't
care at well Daddy still has daddy still
puts it down you understand at 56 daddy
ain't lost a a a stat well you might
have here this this going to hurt a
little bit you might have lost a little
step because she's dreaming of other men
Brian well that's true and I will say
this as well that I don't think like I
don't blame her for not being that
attracted to me cuz my face yeah well I
get 10% uglier every [__] year so it
just depends yeah you know my face my
features are starting to blend yeah you
remember I used to have a sharp nose and
dark hair and now I have a rounder nose
and no I I don't really remember yourse
winter
yeah yeah anyway you'll be all right man
there I was look at me there
Bubba come on dude not bad ah your nose
is a little sharp there little sharp
right little sharp little sharper you
always had a b bit of a bell pepper nose
there you go there that's a really yeah
a bit of aell pepper that's a that's
good look at that cleft in my chin I'm a
jaw yeah that's gone had a jaw back
then yeah anyway can't be all right
can't win them all buddy you'll be all
right had to cry a lot on that show oh I
know yeah you said that with homeboy
real good it's real
fun um okay that's the podcast guys
thanks so much thank you for coming
Brian is p we appreciate that actually
Bri I just looked it up and uh when
people have dreams where they're
cheating it could mean a few things
insecurities in yourself insecurities in
your relationship or a hidden fear of
Abandonment oh damn are you making her
feel abandoned check check check well
you know what's funny is I've been
really preoccupied and last night it's
so interesting you say this because last
night I said uh come here I miss you and
she goes yeah right you don't think
about me she was mad because I'd been so
preoccupied but that's just Brian right
it's the brine show lady that's what you
married no dude I've been married to him
for 12 years it's the brine you you know
what Bubba it's not true I have a little
bit a little bit don't say that out loud
no it's about Brian it's Brian's world
you ever heard of Bobby's World it's
don't say that it's not true I'm very
considerate no I still love you no cons
no what do you mean no I'm considerate I
like how the other day I was like you
have anger issues you're like me I can't
tell you how many people reach out to me
they like oh Brian is the worst
I said I said the the you know how he
has anger issues he doesn't realize it
no I think I have anger issues but I
think I only have anger issues when I
sometimes in life you can't fight back
like you have to shadow box there's
nobody to hit so that's when I get angry
when I feel impotent what if you tell
yourself
dog wait I was trying to think of
something dude oh the Brian show no no
you know what it is your wife bought a
one way ticket into the Brian show now
she's upset she doesn't like the show no
she doesn't like the show that's not
true I do on her hey Danny I've seen the
show no I do on her you pie of [__] no
no no no I'm in it and it is a night
that's not true but listen listen oh D
let me guess your stories don't matter
come on hey hey you're acting like shut
up man you're you're playing a character
listen listen it's because I've been
doting I've been doting on my son he's
he's just this little bunny and I think
I put so much attention on him sometimes
you forget ah not that so it's the kid
fault yeah blame it on the kids take no
responsibility our adorable guys I don't
like the way this podcast is going
man I don't like the way this podcast is
going I uh but maybe that's brought her
to Vegas yeah we had a great time yeah
brought her to Vegas and I like bringing
her with me I love hanging out with her
I have to say I enjoy it can I talk to
you about those shoes you talking about
the Freddy Krueger I don't I don't know
they look uh the Freddy now these are
the Holy Grail of SB Dunks funny story
I'm glad you brought this up no I
bringing the weeds here so these the
they do they did like shy right get
ready this one's fun though even you'll
appreciate this so Nike decided do uh
like a Halloween series they do it every
year and that that this particular year
this is a long time ago this particular
year they did like a Jason one they did
um they did like a zombie one for uh
walking with the dead and then did a
Freddy one but they didn't get approval
from uh New Motion Pictures whatever new
line Motion Pictures oh so they released
them with the Freddy right so it has the
Freddy Krueger sweater on the front has
like the blood splatter on the this
supposed to be like skin color and then
the silver uh Nike swooshes for Freddy's
you know his freaking claws or whatever
so they released these then new line
Simmon comes along goes seasoned assist
what are you doing we didn't give you
approval so Nike goes oh [__] but they
already shipped all the boxes to the
back in the day skateboard shops were
the ones that got the dunks so they go
we need them back well so they did take
some back some people are like these are
so dope we're going to take them so
there's a theory that there's only 30
pairs available cuz not everyone you
know played by the rules and they kept
some of them um so there's a the the
rumor is there's 30 pairs in the world
so if there's 30 pairs in the world and
a fan sent me these the chances of them
being real are not they're not good
because because they probably go for 40
Grand worth of oh 40 Grand would be a
crazy deal on this add 100K onto that
yeah they're probably 140 150 Grand come
look buy for $1
$138,000 cuz it's all about scarcity so
if there's only a 100 or if there's 30
pairs in the world and you wear size 13
so that you think the fan got a
replica good chance yeah they don't look
they they look different than that they
look different color no no the Color
Spot on there's just but see how that's
whiter am I but that's the picture
dumbass right is it yeah like get off
stockx J go to a regular picture they're
pretty spoton but the but you can tell
from the box and then also when Nike got
them they put they dumped a lot of oil
there you go spot on they dumped a lot
of oil on them to set them on fire some
of the workers in the shop grabbed them
so there's some oil marks on them uh
you're going to see certain things I
don't see any oil marks on that though
well I can fix
that I'm sorry listen I'll just wear the
[__] out of saying that on in on air you
may distress them artificially and then
sell them I'll just no I would never
sell them no cuz you can't prove they're
real you just want the Chan of these
being real are I mean it's more likely
that aliens touchdown on Earth yeah 30
pairs in the world and they're size 13
but it's interesting right new line was
like hell no you can't have Freddy
Krueger I know somebody who wrote a book
and they're they're known they wrote a
book and did a whole social media tour
and everything under a certain name and
they didn't bother to check the name
they didn't bother to yeah they they
didn't like copyright the name or
something and then uh they didn't bother
to check the name and they had to well
they had to get rid of the book sir they
had like tell me there's another Moby
Dick all the momentum all that
momentum that's what it was all that
momentum
just killed them I mean killed them he's
like what are the chances Fahrenheit 15
this is nuts dude yeah well my friend my
other friend this is [__] my other
friend did a really good documentary
really good documentary and it it went
out did the whole thing and they got a
letter said hey you don't own that title
who doesn't look into that show correct
but sometimes if you don't day one the
publishing house you can do a
preliminary search but you have to pay
to do a deep search and a lot of times
people do just this they do this
overview like they'll pay somebody they
go well you know we've gone through that
and you see like oh well it's there's no
trademark dude you don't realize and
everything's been done or like
originally with thick boy we had the
chubby thick boy face the smiley face
you know there's a family that's like
100 years old who owns the smiley face
logo so whether it's Justin Bieber Theo
vant I don't care whoever us a smiley
face you have to pay a percentage to
that family and they come for everything
so they came to us they're like love the
logo it's cool you made him chubby we
own that and I was like well no cuz he's
chubby it's different than yours they go
it doesn't matter any sort of uh similar
phase you have to pay us a royalty I how
much is the royalty and they told me I
went I'll find a different design yeah
I'll change it you guys are [__] cuz
Forest Gump came up with this that's
what I told them that's amazing they can
de reference yeah what they can own that
the smiley face yeah they owned it I
wonder if that stretches to like Nirvana
and like I'm telling you everything that
that family is it's a it's a cartel a
smiley face cartel smiley face cartel
smiley face killer smiley face killer
yeah dude those those those serial
killers using a smiley face bro you have
a big Bill coming in the mail yeah big
Bill you worri about cops worry about
that smiley face family yep so we had to
go a different direction cuz it's a lot
of money I'm going to use uh the
pan that's my logo that'd be cool just a
goat with with an impossible dong just
the lower quarters of it now Nike did do
a Air Max 95 in the Freddy Kruegers but
they changed I think there it's more of
like a brown and uh red I like Freddy
Krueger cuz I a kid out of Freddy
Krueger poster yeah and then it would
scare me and my brother my mom said good
kids don't have Freddy Krueger poster so
I got rid of it really it gave me
nightmares like you're wife to scare the
[__] out of you yes I was terrified of
them I love the movies though Freddy
Krueger was a creep huh only attacks you
when in your sleep yes okay dude well my
son who's 12 insists on watching creepy
as [__] movies I thought I was as a kid
but then then he's like like and he
won't admit it he's what kind of movies
though [__] the scariest [__] you can
imagine like what give me a reference I
don't know Conjuring whatever the
Insidious all those movies that's a lot
for a 12-year-old huh yeah I was more to
like it like I would as he got obsessed
with it too it the the new it is [__]
out of me SC yes he went all he's down
that's old that's that's old hat for him
meanwhile he watched it I'm like what
are you doing man he's like what I know
it's a movie time to go to bed he's like
uh uh can you you you can leave the
light on yeah I'm like leave the light
on like yeah go and leave the light on
and door open if you that's some that sh
I was the same way I love being scared I
was so scared as a kid yeah but then
he's got to go to bed and he's like fly
that's how I was dude that's how I was
but then I don't know I gotta figure out
who Tiger's hanging out with because
originally he wanted to be like a zombie
for Halloween now he's like I want be
text chainsaw I'm like the [__] you
talking about yeah that's weird he's
yeah we text chainsaw he's like and dad
we'll get a fake uh we'll get a fake
chainsaw and we put like chicken meat on
it I'm like what the [__] are you
talking about yeah I go do you know what
the Tex chainsaw is he's like no I'm
like ah it's not for kids dude yeah they
get what happened to the cute
zombie there is a new Tex this chainsaw
video game I know UFC was promoting it
what mhm UFC was promoting it were you a
video game guy big time you were big I
don't think so to jam and Earl [__] yeah
but you weren't me and my brother played
nonstop you did oh yeah but when we were
in sports it was video game what was
your uh favorite
game um I mean I like I never played him
I never grew up with him well yeah was
like pong back in the day yeah okay dude
yeah it's different I never oh did you
not play Tetris no dude we did
everything I was talking we had 3dio we
had the Jaguar we had the Sega we had
the Nintendo I mean we did it all dude
Mortal Kombat Street Fighter Contra
Super Mario Mario Kart golden eye Tow
Jam and Earl Oddworld metal Gill Metal
Gear Solid I like being so old I Need
for Speed Gran Turismo I'll go all
[__] day you piece of [__] Jes I
don't believe you though well you didn't
have that to SJ I mean I didn't have
that well you're Savage I said I I said
to deah last night I go uh Hey man uh I
want I got to sell more tickets I got
this show in Greensboro you got any
advice you goes yeah do
theaters then he goes I go no come on
don't be a dick he goes all right all
right let me see do only fans show your
feet you're Tain he hung up I FaceTime
him again he anwers like this he's
dead so funny oh my God
[__] hilarious yeah yeah I'm old um I
think when you're in my age you can't
even I don't think I can dance right
only at my daughter's wedding but I
can't dance it's a little weird it's
like watching a dog eat broccoli or
something it's like what are you trying
to attract a mate it's weird it it's
like a like a up up like beat no slow
even especially if I'm good at Dan Frank
Sinatra and [__] where are you trying to
dance though well my we went out went
out my wife was like hold my let's dance
and I was like oh boy my wife loves at
where do you dance at this St we were we
were we were at a we went to dinner with
some with a couple friend of ours and
then we went to this bar and there was
dancing that's annoying is that an amber
alert no it's National alert it's a
national alert we all knew it's going to
happen if your phone's not on silent
it's going to happen there you go my
phone's on silent my phone's on silent
too well my phone's on silent it's not
going
through was supposed to happen that was
one of the current events no it's got to
be do not disturb oh so it's like this
is this a national test to make sure
that when we release the co again that
you guys all yeah yeah the conspiracy
people are going wild about this yeah no
no they announced it yesterday I I was
going to use it as a current event but I
didn't think our phones would go off oh
yeah they
they and they're going crazy over this
what is
this but yeah well remember remember
remember in Hawaii they did the someone
messed up and it was like the worst one
coming the worst one ever yeah someone
like miscalculated hit the button it was
like atomic bomb everyone save yourself
yeah they at one point they thought um
what is that we're wondering the same
thing oh Crowder post
this oh can't do
that I don't know if that's the place to
dance You Can Dance someone said why is
this old man starting to humiliate
himself hey you son [__] be cool man
why why had this old man started
humiliating himself lately like
this to sell tickets bro it's going to S
tickets bro I mean you know have a
little Charity sir try to put that's one
strange animal yeah any you're a little
stiff though huh I'm a little stiff but
you and your wife were dancing
where we went to this [__] club this
bar and it turned out there was a dance
floor she like let's dance in a bar and
I'm holding her purse as she's dancing
and I'm doing this and I'm like you know
I'm too gray and I don't want I used to
like to dance I want to dance no there's
really no place at a concert I can see
like like my girl goes to these Mexican
concerts and they're dancing their ass
that's your girl it's like sexy and at a
concert in a bar though yeah with a
dance bar there was dance it was a dance
thing you know dance it was at a place I
think it was called
Chestnut [__] know in Santa Monica
they bar get rid of that but bar get rid
of that dance floor yeah you don't see
it these days dude no the only time
dancing is really but there a lot of
people dancing though there were a lot
of peoplek to May it was in New York I
can't remember hey make the story up no
no I can't remember no I appreciate it
for Content but that never happened
especially recently it did happen in New
York it was in Santa Monica I guess
maybe it was in New York I'd have to
call yeah I'd have to call we went to a
club a club or bar dude I can't remember
it was a club it might have been two
instances one was at a
going to a club hey look up Chestnut in
Santa Monica and see if there's a dance
floor there downstairs I don't even like
going it's downstairs it's near there
never mind it's Santa mon can you
imagine going to a club right
now bottle
service that's it's the place around it
there's place behind it okay no no not
chestnuts what I just told you look up
it's behind it yeah hey it's all good
daddy no no no it's behind it um it
never happened it's all right yeah yeah
yeah I was I remember holding her purse
going this is just Why I just can't do
this anymore I can't I just can't
imagine myself in a club are you Kidd
can't imagine like like yeah like in
Vegas I remember when I was young like
in my 20s I'd go and you'd see like 40
year olds 50y olds in there with like
ordering bottle service with like hot
chicks now I'm older I'm like what a
loser loser I I I actually think if
you're in my Ag and you're wearing
you're too into fashion you have a
bracelet you know you see these guys
where you're like there's just too much
going on something's up there I it just
looks unnatural to me I don't it just
depends if you're a billionaire and
you're Italian and you have long gray
hair maybe I can understand like like
there's something about just being like
I'm GNA know that guy who's that awesome
guy who dances with his hot young wife
on a yacht and he in a speedo oh that
guy's cool he's in a speed though that
great so a billionaire they're so bored
there's so bored they're so bored at the
end of the day they're [__] what else
can they do and they're like [__] it
give me a speedo I'll dance that's it
like I mean you get a lot of tattoos in
your 40s and 50s something's up
something's
up
right so good chance are you looking him
up no cuz how do you look him up old guy
dancing in Speedo he was he was all the
rage for a while and I think he just
decided I got to stop he died yeah but
we we we had him on uh we played him on
the show before many times man dancing
Rogan loved himan just he put Rogan in a
good in a good mood that's a dude oh
yeah he's in shape too he's in great
shape can't play the music but that's
him yeah ah Gian GI he's
fantastica yeah yeah and he was on uh he
was on Vine he's pulling his shorts down
so you can see his hips he's in
phenomenal shape yeah yeah yeah he was
obviously a complete stud when he was in
his 20s and 30s and he's a stud now but
he's you're crazy if this ad didn't end
he just [__] slimed her in the face
dude dude sliming dude what excuse
what excuse me Happ after that don't say
slim you think she's there to do Tick
Tock dances yes I do she's there to
carry the load no can you not say that
please I don't appreciate it now as soon
as that video ended it was Drake's new
cover no but she's not Halle Berry no
but she was covered in slime no got
januca vachi I'm 55 health is not just
about eating healthy and exercising oh
God save it dude he has a tattoo across
his tongue
oh man I'm embarrassed by oh oh oh no no
too many too many rings too many rings
you can't be that vain unless you're
Chris Angel don't wear Rings thing on
his
go well you know then he he just stopped
the views were going down he just
stopped well that's probably what you
want to do after a while how many times
can you watch a man in his 50s dance 55
yeah there's your boy he does look good
yeah oh god oh he is tatted up he's
tatted up it looks like he says Festival
oh man he's a he's a lot going on he's a
good dude I believe
actually he made his money uh his family
has a lot of money it doesn't matter
either way doing the damn thing damn he
has a go to his Prime video there's a
documentary on him called Mucho MTH
where's that yeah the one where it
lookss like a cover of a movie nope go
up Jin above the yeah there you go there
it is
25 dude dude that guy slimes dude please
no don't say that I don't like that
that's with the kids no cap that's he's
sliming dude oh [__] [__] that [__]
you want to see the trailer we can't
play course I want to see the trailer
that that documentary has been cool for
about 10 minutes yeah and you're going
to go I got it I got it after the
trailer so oh yeah that's all I need to
see either way he's kind of crushing it
I mean it it depends on oh he says he's
a pop star though yeah it's he's like
retired pop star he's a mess is what I
would call him he's a [__] mess boy
if that's a mess sign me up dude
okay that's he's 56 now 22 million
followers dude I think he was a big pop
star back in the day I don't think so
babba a d interal DJ I think he had a
rich dad the success of one of the most
famous Italians in the world yeah I
think he had ask how he made his money
you're you know what you don't know and
you're hating on him you're hating on
him bring it up CH hey look at me I do
know do you yeah let's see I do know so
so um he uh he comes from some money
mhm
yeah oh a large stockholder in a
manufacturing business called EMA I
wonder if his dad owns that or his
family bring it up chin damn it so let's
find out because you just end up being a
stockholder out of
nowhere how did it says Emily I promise
you I promise
you you before the
fame go back uh no ke we'll find it here
all right let me go how'd this guy find
get his damn money oh uh no uh his
family go to his family when you click
on the family see it says uh V family V
family you can't click on or you well if
you go down it's his family probably
keep it a guarded
secret yeah oh but just that's his
personal family yeah damn net worth 2500
mil yeah he's he's a he comes from U
there's a there's a whole contingent of
those young men my age who whose parents
were very very wealthy Italian like
Italian aristocracy they went they went
to
school uh dad Rich yeah yeah me go back
probably a good chance but no it's it's
yeah it's a good chance
promise that's how a lot of kids right
espe the St age I I actually I'll tell
you
why I tell you
why it's hilarious I don't see anything
it keep going down yeah he did he made
it on social
media I went business man it doesn't say
anything why you say businessman an
artist you're like mm keep going
down his father Marco was the chairman
of a bank and owned the Ima
a multinational firm there you go
Brian's right yeah oh his dad owned a
bank yeah okay oh you mean his dad owned
a bank where they hold money yes yes
born at my age chairman of the yeah and
pharmaceutical okay St owned em and
Multinational firm oh oh that manufactur
the company is Dad owns is currently
worth $3.5 billion okay check please
there you go kids yeah what' I tell you
k solv k Sol Bubba come on man couple of
being a hater
no the father no I know some people who
might know him still living it up yeah
he's a rich kid he's always done that
yeah and now he's uh at that age
sometimes I do think you get to an age
where you're like what do I do here
what's going on with my life like I'm M
he's in shape had a kid this is a
picture of him at the age of 25 I do
believe Del Photoshop got his hair as a
train wct there yeah he was uh
yeah that's him working for his dad with
his hair yeah or just dressed in a suit
Italian style with that pocket thing the
whole thing's a nightmare yeah there's a
whole there's a whole uh he seems much
there's a whole tradition there's a
whole like sort of like that Italian
thing where your son is allowed to not
grow up I really what is yeah Mommy
makes excuses for you she does literally
when you're Italian in Italy and I'm not
kidding like a kid like that I promise
you his mother he has never done laundry
not once his mother's done that's how it
should be his mother does his laundry
and and she still does his laund why is
this a problem no I'm just saying I wish
my mom did my laundry yeah that'd be
[__] sick my mom did my laundry all
the time he's never made a bed and he's
never done his laundry and I mean never
living dude yeah it talian do it right
yes and by the way he's never cooked a
meal for himself probably when he was
older maybe he was like you know for a
girl I can cook and Mama give me some
you know but for the most part no yeah
very I don't see any problems there this
guy gets especially upper you know class
but but the Italy they WR about it it's
a it's an issue America's the only
Americans are only on who when the kid
turn 16 you kick them out of the house
all other I love I love the Italian
culture I love like your your
grandparents live with you you know you
don't kick them out that's why so many
of them die that's just not Italy that's
that's everywhere Middle East everywhere
everywhere England that's why people are
America's the only one that kicks you
out of the house at 16 gross and they
want you to go your own way it's nasty
it destroys the family I think it's
[__] yeah me too so I'd let my kids
love me as long as they want [__] yeah
dude how about how about people who send
their kids away to boarding school
that's what happened to you who was the
kid who got sent no but there's a kid
who's got probably there's a kid who got
sent away at but that was my
choice good on no it was it you keep
going all right you're right yeah it
definitely
wasn't no send me away to this foreign
land without any friends or family dad
my choice to go to a different to live
in a different country every a year and
a half and then be and then go to the
United States where my parents are still
Saudi Arabia you know what I like about
this you're taking accountability you're
lying to yourself but there's some
accountability tell me I have to go to
Massachusetts Bo school I never lived in
the United States I'm 14 Brian you for
the first time we're Atty Massachusetts
boarding school you got stay in here
yeah Saudi Arabia yeah got to say bye to
my dog yeah we're actually going to kill
the dog when we leave
good good
good good yeah kind of [__] me up a
little bit I bet but um there was a kid
who was sent to boarding school at 7
years old
who the [__] was it that's a Spartan
lifestyle who was it um that's just bad
parenting yeah it's it's an actor an
actor's kid who things aren't going well
for him um name an actor the kids are a
nightmare
yeah oh um [__] um his parents were
super
famous both his parents were really
famous big actor oh shar's sher's son
shar's Sher sunny and sher's son she the
kid has been have he has major drug
problems and Sher just had men kidnap
him from his wife sher's son reportedly
found Banner when he was sent to a
boarding school at such young age s
years old while Sher thought it would be
best for Elijah the lack of proper
father figure made him constantly Pine
for one trying to bond with various men
his mother dated so his mother have you
seen who shar's dating lat she dates
yeah she's dating a guy 40 years her
Junior yeah so she dates all these
different men and and and this kid is
sent away to boarding school at 7 years
old can you IM your son's seven can you
[__] imagine you miss one of his
baseball games you freak out can you
imagine I can't even imagine it I
wouldn't send my kid my son's 12 there's
not a shot i' my son came even stay the
night at his friend's house for a
night to me that's the so if you want to
be famous and you want to make it the
share the sunny and share show the share
show sh Show good good for you but I
don't that that's not how you raised the
son in my opinion oh guess what the kid
has the kid has major heroin problem
yeah 47 and he's been he's been in out
of rehab ter mom awful mom so then his
mom goes she he's married and they're in
a hotel and his mother hires four men to
kidnap him at 47 that's right sir kidnap
him but does he have like a horrible
drug problem at this point I guess he's
back to trying not to use or
something and then her other her other
daughter turned into a man Chaz Bono oh
yeah boy she's
B
yes um damn that was recently hired
Forman a kidnapper adult yeah oh yeah
from his hotel room in November she
because she doesn't trust that he's not
going to kill himself he had some
near-death experiences with overdoses
wow look she loves her son what did you
watch a documentary on Shar I read a
thing about it J Christ yeah I read a
whole thing about it because you know
sometimes the worst thing you can do for
your kid is become rich and famous maybe
a lot and well be a bad parent there's a
lot of parents who are rich and famous
who are good parents yeah you got to be
there for the kids yeah but you're still
batt Aon ker in and uh his wife yeah
they're good
parents yeah like Rogan's a great dad
he's more famous than [__] all these
people we're talking about he's a great
dad y it's all about the parenting
that's on share that's on you [__] 100%
on share yeah go sing another song with
your tits right I don't know dude yeah
she's 77 bring her up she looks what
whoever her doctor is I want that doctor
her pioneering e like is just set the
tone for plastic surgery it does right
100% she was probably the first what
happened with Madonna well she went to a
different doctor like I can do the same
for 10% discount yeah let's get into
that what do you so Shar shar's been
doing it forever click on the that's her
so that's her boyfriend but look at her
she's
77 dude you and Shar have the same size
legs no don't say that dude you're going
to make me mad there are certain things
I just won't stand for on this podcast
and that's one of them she does look
good click on that one with her with the
uh no go back click on the one with her
with the uh real live uh Wolverine right
there there we go real life well that's
Versace right that's yeah that's Miss
Versace sheer looks phenomenal isn't
that crazy you can touch up pictures
right um um s what is what's going on
who is her doctor how does that happen
like why why her why does she look like
that and Madonna looks something else is
it is it the way her face is structured
I can't even figure I mean she's always
had great bone structure we get that but
I don't know like for 10 points what's
her National Gold ever T Brennan what's
her nationality Armenian yes thank you
dude thank you sarian I think is their
last
name yeah you can
tell wow look she's a force in nature
looks like a human cat huh all about her
ain't it Rari looks like that the movie
Cats dude I'm going to look just like
that when I'm H go go to cats chin type
in the cats it's the same [__] thing
from the movie or from the musical
either either
or I mean that's different terrible how
brother
died yeah shot that's what she looks
like that's Taylor Swift being
sweet um yeah she's a she's got a it's
[__] tough dude the monkeyy pause
time time father time there's
Versace uh well let's bring up Madonna's
Instagram stag because she seems to be
uh that's a train she yeah she seems to
not be wanting but I'd rather be Shar or
uh Versace or Madonna
than all right damn it I don't know Dam
you didn't know how to spell Madonna put
m o instead of ma oh wow that's a simple
come on dude well there she looks decent
At first she looks cool uhhuh uhuh It's
just tough to tell right what's that on
her wait go back what what's that on her
those are in ears like this yeah she's
seeing in ear monitors yeah she took
them out Jesus but they're flesh colored
so they look weird but go back oh man go
back yeah mean let's see the whole page
did yeah she's doing the damn thing
uhhuh lot of fillers she's a it's tough
on IG cuz the the filters and
stuff wow and she has that dump truck
out the back
yeah she is
just stay young ladies and gents yeah
fighting Father Time Father Time's
undated that is such a yeah that's such
a that's such a an assault on time she's
doing the best she can she's fighting
man I tell you what sheer looks like
she's winning the rounds though I'm GNA
get some filler that's it I'm but how
but how old is
Madonna 70 something
60 65 66 65 wow that's not that's not
too old it's not
young I mean the way she looks can do
you know what I'm saying she's trying
all right what do you got Jen wow all
right guys let's play a little game a
game if you're down yeah let's do it so
there's like a little pirate Barrel
there in the middle of you this thing
yeah okay and then oh so yeah so you
guys have little swords don't do it yet
so there's a thing I wanted to try with
both of you guys
so I found the most powerful stun gun on
Amazon I'm not doing that come on dude
I'm G to do it with you guys no I'm not
doing that [__] you [__] you are you
serious hell yeah I'm serious how if I
do it first and then we'll play
absolutely not I I hate that I'll do it
if you if we lose we just sting you no
no sting me first and then play the game
how how about we just sting
you you don't mind being come on this
would be great I got a bad ticker I just
can't there's not a shot I'm doing
that oh my God this kill game I still
want to see someone get stung with I'll
get stung you guys St sting me I've I've
been stun gunned by like three different
stun guns D but are are you one of those
guys that you're that you're not you can
deal with it like where it doesn't
affect you or no I don't know I just
tried it well but I have not tried this
one this supposed to be the most
powerful one with 50 million or
something thank you no chit hey we need
ratings but Jesus Christ I don't want to
die Vince thing or yeah do it to me you
want me to do it to you I'll do it stand
up in front of the cameras and do it so
is our best stun gun the stun gun also
comes with safety disable pin as
powerful as 51 million volts which can
definitely zap your target faster than
most stun guns out there all right so
all I got to do is CH I like this dude
for the views oh my just press this and
then where did you buy this at Amazon
holy [__] that's up and then you want me
to just touch you hold on hold on hold
on let me hold on hold
on hold on [__] it's going to hurt I
know oh my God Brian do it for the
camera
chin this is Chin's idea chin wants this
go
[__] [__] okay you did it twice oh
that's all that's all it you smell the
burer right yeah fine no [__] that what
the [__] I don't like that
stuff they did it [__] hurts but it's
not going to kill you that's what I'm
saying like stun guns won't stop you oh
they'll stop you they just stink it'll
hurt yeah yeah I don't want it hey guess
what my life's a pain in the ass I
don't no thanks I hate that stuff at
least you got yeah that did that didn't
really do much to you though chin I
thought it would like knock you to the
it burn me I thought it would knock you
to the [__] uh ground but that's not
going to do anything that doesn't stop
people does it that's what I'm saying I
always told you guys this it doesn't
stop you holy [__] you know what I like
though chin was down to do it I I like
chin had the idea for the
views I I'll stay with my low views and
I get shocked though oh me too
go and God bless you I don't like that
well they they uh when it's bad when you
have electrod attached to your balls and
they just go ch's like all right fellas
views are down I brought a 9mm and we're
going to play Russian Roulette no I
googled this quite a bit so I looked at
if 50 million volts can kill you and
this is just from quora says lethal
voltage happen well below 2 million
that's 50 million CH but when it come
what if I died when it cont when it
actually contacts your body the voltage
changes for some sure whatever that's
dude why would they sell it on Amazon if
you can kill people but Chim that didn't
do anything to you no it hurt it definit
and you can smell the burning right
isn't it supposed to like go aren't you
it's supposed to drop you yeah and I've
tried three different ones with my
friends you want to try you running at
me I do it to your heart do it to my
heart right now I'm that's going [__]
hurt chin I'm not even kidding it's not
worth it man no I'm not doing that [__]
no you do it to him yeah do it to my
heart I'm not even joking it's not going
to do [__] it's not going to do [__]
just try I feel like it's a bad idea
kill him kill chin you want them view
you really want me to do it slay
chin don't kill our look at brenon like
shaking his head cut to us next podcast
well we didn't want to do it and uh on
record remember I didn't want to kill
yeah so this is the button
press it's [__] bright too
man you want to do it to your heart let
me you have a shirt on what the hell you
put skins man no I don't know is it
going to burn the shirt no I don't know
well I'll get you new Bel go for it
ready yeah here well run at me like a
hate crime I don't want to run you run
at me and say you white piece of [__]
yeah try need some motivation you just
got to be like [__] Korea for every
white piece of
[__] [__] you did test it hurt yeah it
hurts that one definitely hurts yeah and
than you can smell the burning right I
don't know I don't smell any burning
burning I don't like this your CL shut
[__] you know what if you wanted to pick
me up chin all you needed was a magic
mind listen some people like to buy stun
guns to wake up we use magic mind use
magic mind because this gives me the
alert feeling I needs you know what
every day I struggle with should I Jam a
volt of 50 million volts into my body or
should I just use a magic mine and thank
God magic M Works CU I don't need a volt
I'm getting my matcha and all my
adaption and this when you cut to Chin
getting vted and then cut back to Bri
taking magic KN that's right that's
right you use a volt you use voltage are
you sick of electrocuting yourself we
have just the answer do you want to pick
me up do you want to feel alert and
amazing huh huh sure you can take a stun
gun to the dick or you can try magic
right uhhuh chin decides to use the stun
gun I love this stuff I was wondering
what this game I was like man this
game's going to sh we didn't get to play
it which sucks I wanted to Chin I love
your idea dude I love it I see where
you're going with it I get the
creativity it's
brilliant no you know what I like you're
not going to die from it you're going
die I appreciate your effort and I'm
serious and I think that was an awesome
game and I know you super creative I
love it I love it I'm just not going to
participate I'm AF fine I did that
shooting thing where they I had to wear
it on my back and I like and it sucked
it does suck it hurts J's like new game
guys I have three powders there one is
pure fentanyl let's just sniff it see
what happens yeah dude I appreciate it
chin he going to bring out a murder
Hornet and you're going to have to like
you know all right so current events you
know what I'd rather deal with a murder
Hornet than that stone g that thing I
can bat down stomp on it's the sound
that's the most scary my God that was
but it does hurt like a [__] you
remember in The Girl with the Dragon
Tattoo when she comes in and stuns the
guy with that and he like passes out
I think some people that it'll do it too
but I think so if you're like getting
attacked by someone and you do that
right away for sure it's going to freak
them out right but it's not going to
drop them it won't stop them right is
that the same is that the same thing as
uh the gun that shoots the bar no those
for sure I would not want to do the pins
see those in the military and they're
like I think that's way more actual
tasers yeah the tasers look like they
stop but stun guns I'm like dude I've
tried like three
four you just go it hurts like there
only one way to go chin we got to use a
Taser
next if you guys are down I'm down yeah
[__] that have you been tased never no
never no but by the way Brian you're
right pepper spray or mace 100% will
take you down I've been it oh yeah I've
been taken down by Ma you don't want to
[__] around with that yeah it's it
messes you
up uh this is great right is so
impossibly strong than you realize what
I thought this was cuz that's at the old
um Zoo culture where I go in Woodland
Hills he has a new one in Ceno but this
is him it must have been an older uh
starting top this is him wrestling with
Brian Shaw who's the former strongman
and this is posted on October 3rd a row
he's still pretty
[Music]
strong he's like lifting him like a
little
kid I could have put my foot any further
back be fair you're strong though I
just Brian's so nice he's so nice you're
strong
St yeah the problem where Brad messed up
Bradley messed up it let him get under
hooked yeah how you know he doesn't know
how to wrestle like you would never give
a guy like Brian Shaw any advantage to
get under hooks ever you would not let
him get under never because that's what
you do you go for stop him from getting
under hooks though when he's that strong
there's techniques there's the there's
wrest was in and oh there's wrestlers
that would annihilate brain Shaw
annihilate yeah and who are way less if
you don't know how to wrestle who are
way less yeah but yeah I mean his first
[__] up this what you know he [__] up
right is when he gave him under Hooks
and because all Brian SCH now it's like
him lifting a cake yeah just lift just a
human he's
boom like right when he shoots Brian
knows what he's doing he shoots straight
for the inside yep boom screwed yeah
screwed you're done there and then he's
not pushing on the hips there he's like
he's not doing anything right so when
you're when you guys are in heavy ways
you're you're you're fighting for
underhooks all the time all the time
underhooks is so when you're like in the
cage against the guy might be over under
but double o underhook double underhook
is disaster disaster you're going down
you're too strong you give a guy DC
that's his DC's thing inside you give a
underhook you're screwed
man what else you got D all right next
one is a couple of bear attacks this is
in b like that beers are fighting back
dude I mean especially in Canada dude
Trudeau's trying to make it straight up
North Korea you see they're going to
start limiting social media and they
have they have you can't get your social
media no now they're they're it's like
straight North Korea Vibes it's crazy
dude they're trying to pass this law
that is going to put regulations on all
social media yeah the IDE is well we
want to we want to cut down on
misinformation and we're going to show
you only what we want to show you it's
North Korea like North Korea thinks
we're we're like The Walking Dead they
show videos of them like blowing us up
and it never
happened even the war they're like we
won they're like hell yeah and they get
like hey what happened well Canadians
have to wake up Canadians have to go I
can't this cannot be Canadians are too
nice okay you lose your [__] feedom
freedoms but I I was asked I was going
to go hiking in
bamp and I knew there were grizzly bears
there somebody told me there were
grizzly bears there and I didn't go
hiking in B that's that's for real so
this older couple hour and a half away
from where I was and I was like oh I'm
not going to oh there are grizzly bears
there I'm not going hiking I would go so
this couple they've been they know the
the woods like you know just as much as
anyone else they've been they've been
doing it forever they've been you know
they know all the protocols if you
there's a grizzly bear whatever they've
been camping forever together they're
Inseparable couple they both got killed
and their dog got killed how old were
they and their dog I I think they're
seniors or something like that damn and
their dog [__] yeah oh you think the dog
was going to get away
oh dude a grizzly bear is a nightmare oh
yeah they live for being in the back
country and were two of the most
cautious people I know the new beer
protocol oh really what's that all that
stuff oh yes you you know what a bear
protocol is you bring a [__] don't
run away or or you or you have the the
the be spray doesn't always work though
no but you know what works is like you
know the the burglar spray that we that
they have like 50 yards away you spray
that it'll back them up no see what bear
spray should be way more powerful than
regular spray no no no you know what I
conflict that because you're supposed to
use bear spray against burglar oh it
works like a mother other incidents
incidents from this year include a black
bear that killed a man at his Campsite
in Arizona and a polar bear killed a
woman and her one-year-old son in a
small village in Alaska yeah so they're
different areas but as far as ban it's
this is like the first killing in like
two decades I know but when so so so
here's how you get really cautious with
bears you carry a 44 yeah a gun for sure
[__] gun says b National Park home to
roughly 60 grizzly bears not terrible no
20 to 40 black bears chance of seen them
not great think how many people go
through b how many have been attacked by
bears your odds are pretty good sure
what's funny though in the headlines
okay so anyways for B at least it it was
like what two decades since there's a
death but before that there was like
three attacks non- fatal but then
another thing came out and this is in
Montana a woman like 73 got attacked by
a grizzly bear they just attacked the
old and her husband took took a a bear
spray and was able to back him off and
they got to she got airlifted and she's
apparently they don't know the condition
but she should be okay yeah so that's a
second bear attack within
like in October or no wait is a general
rule like if it's brown laid down if
it's a black fight back like like I
think that's what it is sounds racist
what's I'm fighting back no matter what
that's the rule if it's brown lay down
but they say that then then that cub
scout leader was trying to show his Cub
Scouts cuz they ran into a Grizzy Bear
he's like just watch every buddy I'm
going to lay down it's not going to be
an issue and the Grizz bear is like holy
what are you doing dude I'm going to eat
you ass first in front of these kids and
the kids like no you need brown brown
lay down black fight back white good
night oh polar
bear but here are some of the here's
some of the rules here no no okay no no
I hear you yeah yeah talk calmly slowly
wave your arms stay calm it's just a gz0
don't scream Hol tip pick up pick up
small children don't let kids run away
no hiking groups make yourself look big
oh yeah yeah I'll try that good don't
drop your bag walk away slowly again
don't run don't climb trees I can't cuz
they can climb so basically have a gun
if have a gun but I'll climb a tree and
good luck bear I'm GNA [__] curb
stomp your stupid snout yeah I need a I
need a gun you need a gun I saw this
afterwards too yeah so they want to
reintroduce grizzly bears to Washington
State and I wonder why that was a case
and then I looked up why Grizzly be
that's Washington just being
Washington so grizzly bears are known as
keystone species and they're I guess an
important part of the
ecosystem they disperse seeds till the
land fertilize forest and help regulate
prey species dramatically uh oh
interesting so they're taking our job
was very interesting but people are not
happy about that obviously toss them in
there mix it up this one's uh pretty bad
I'm not going to show the video on youth
football shooting so 11-year-old kid
shot two of his own teammates because I
mean they were chasing after they
dropped the ball I'll show you I don't
want to see this I'll show you the video
but we're not going to put on there kids
get killed no no no they're fine well
they're injured injured but they're not
dead so so that kid runs to his car
that's his mom's car apparently and he
knows his mom has a gun in there yeah
which is not in a safe or anything and
he
shoots so apparently he shot one shot
but that one shot got both those kids
that were chasing him and thankfully
they're still alive like it was like a
elbow and a a back
shooting it it seems like it we don't
know 100% but she's freaking out again
bad parenting why does your 11-year-old
know where the gun is in the car why do
you have a gun in the car the whole
thing's a nightmare oh my God that's
insane so he is now charged sport
serious man second uh one count of
second degree attempted murder at 11
years old that's
terrible yeah yeah we can't have that
like kids life's going to get pretty
tough I think his mom's going to be the
one that's punished the most they're
both both it's a disaster it's a
nightmare that's why the mom's freaking
out she's like I'm [__] she should
have known better yeah can't have a gun
like that uh have you guys seen this
video no so this is in Philadelphia
we've all been there and sometimes you
see like ATVs and Motorcycle sorry me
and brenon and I'm sure Brian but
sometimes you see like people with
motorcycles ATV is just like on the
streets sure kind of randomly going by
so this Happ Rough Riders this happened
near uh a woman and her kids and then I
guess one of the bikers accidentally hit
her car and then they got an argument
and this is what happened afterwards so
the car he's stomping is a mother with
kids then gets out of her car to
confront the man oh she ain't messing
around no she's not jumped out and I was
going at him and I end up pushing his
bike over and everybody just started
surrounding me uh so she defended
herself and then apparently the guy was
finally arrested him no no no this a
commercial oh
this is him he's some like he looks like
a douchebag some young Dum douchebag a
little [__] and apparently he actually
pulled out a little like a tiny gun when
she started pushing back hilarious
against a girl yeah and then you're
really tough you and your 50 biker yeah
you guys are I think as soon as they
noticed she was a girl that's why they
otherwise they would probably attacked
her but they a guyd a lot of trouble
just it's just [__] Behavior yeah but
thankfully he's he's caught they need to
look after Ron prman Jesus Christ be
embarrassed
he'll be out slap on the wrist though
yeah all right the balls on her right
getting out of the car got give her mama
bear yeah [__] that guy that guy's a
terrible human being the whole biker
gang he needs that guy we should get
that Italian [__] Instagram guy to
dance on him yeah dance [__] slime them
out [__] yeah slime them out dance on
and slime them out slime them up God
it's so gross yeah it's nasty right came
kid here's another video we we can't
show but um yeah Jesus Christ the uh
yeah this one's a little rough uh it's
pretty much a plane that's doing a
straight nose dive in Ohio and um it did
not end it's a private plane or it's
like a looks like a little two-seater to
me let me see chin yo what the so that's
the footage and I I heard that like uh
two people passed away people died and
one was like damn one survived I think
so yeah
impressive yeah that's pretty crazy
that's a
bummer it's I wonder what caused that
plane to crash
I mean sometimes you lose power right
you can lose power up there one of your
engines goes out there's a lot you can
get icing on your on your wings and when
you get icing on your wings that throws
off everything and it can't cruise with
even with the wings just so heavy the
idea is is you want to cruise the idea
is you can Collide but sometimes you're
going a tail spin like that and you
can't pull it out especially if your
engines don't work you can't pull out of
it it's a bad way to go bad way to
go this is a little bit older but these
are some Instagram videos I found and
sent the
chin a modern day
football kick his ass
fight
fight that's terrible parenting and
coaching these kids are just fighting
they're not even playing football yeah
you getting whooped n no get up keep
whooping them it's bad parenting yep
what the bad parents
episode it started with Sher and now
we're ending with this kid we're not
ending with this it's a straight up
fight I he's trying to make the kids
tough I
guess the laugh was the craziest part I
would beat the [__] out of that coach
yeah but this kid this kid has a
future oh he's
so oh my god well that kid has a future
sitting on the couch watching
TV this kid's never playing football at
to the pee level he's too big too
slow oh my God that number four is like
all right all right dude he's probably
40 how old is yeah you know he's
pretending to be a kid uh let's get to
the Trevor barer thing there it is so
this is insane you going to the accuser
didn't settle a lwuit so that's already
[__] yeah M this is from New York
Post so for those of you that don't know
about Trevor Boward Trevor bow was sa
Young Award winner for the Dodgers top
one of the top pitchers in the league
during the height of the me me to
movement in 2022 especially believe all
women this lady comes out accuses them
all this horrible horrendous stuff which
if it's true it'd be insane right so
we're like oh I can't believe this the
Dodgers they do a investigation kick
this guy off the team remember sa Young
Award winner kick him off the team he's
going through all this legal stuff he
can't say his side because of the due
process comes out I'll let you take it
from here Brian turns out this was a hit
job this lady had all the intentions of
doing this and he shows the evidence of
her in the Tex exchanges two who her
friends going how much is he worth 51
million go get him girl you I would
hoard out for I got to get Daddy to
choke me out first I got to get Daddy to
choke me out this is the biggest here
what [__] up here's what's really
messed up she should go to jail another
player on the padr he plays for the
Dodgers right for the Padre goes I'll
introduce you to him how much is he
worth 51 million I and she goes I'll
send you 50 5K if you do it yeah he's a
then the day she said that she was you
know assaulted punch in the face she for
this the they find out the video that's
all fake the video that day she says the
accus she puts a video of him sleeping
and she's smiling in bed of straight up
video all it's fake scumbag that is
she's the most evil this guy's career is
ruined he's going to sue the Dodgers Sue
MLB they were privy to this she should
go to jail for oh you know what happens
nothing nothing happens to her and she
should go to jail for 20
years play the video of Trevor Bower
this is so disgusting next victim star
pcture for the Dodgers a text lindsy
Hill sent to a friend before she ever
even met me what should I steal she
asked another in reference to visiting
my house for the first time the answer
take his money so how might that work
I'm going to his house Wednesday she
said I already have my hooks in you know
how I roll then after the first time we
met net worth is 51 mil she said said
[__] you better secure the bag was the
response uh but but how was she going to
do that need daddy to choke me out she
said being an absolute [__] to try to
get in on his 51 million read another
text then after the second time we met
former Padre's pitcher Jacob Nicks told
her you got to get this bag I'll give
you 50,000 Lindsay replied her AA
sponsor asked her at one point do you
feel a tiny bit guilty not really she
replied since then her legal team has
approached me multiple times about
coming to a financial settlement but as
I have done since day one I refused to
pay her even a single scent uh in August
of 2021 lindsy Hills claims were heard
in court and during those legal
proceedings critical information was
deliberately and unlawfully concealed
from me and my legal team uh information
like this video which was taken by
Lindsay Hill herself the morning after
she claimed she was brutally attacked
emotionally traumatized and desperate to
get away from me and now we have the
metadata so there can be no dispute uh
it was taken mere minutes before she
left my house on the morning of May 16th
2021 without my knowledge or consent of
course uh in it you can see her lying in
bed next to me while I'm sleeping
sparking at the camera without a care in
the world or any marks on her face God
what I think it paints a pretty clear
picture of what actually happened the
evening of May 15th and why the video
was originally concealed from
us yeah uh after hearing the evidence
available to her judge Diana gold
saltman found that lindsy Hill had
misled the court she found her claims to
be materially misleading uh she denied
her request for a domestic violence
restraining order and she found that no
sexual assault or non-consensual conduct
took place now some of you might not
know about restraining order hearings I
know I didn't but uh I've since learned
that uh it's extremely rare for a
request for a restraining order to be
denied because the standard of proof
that you need to obtain one is extremely
low so you can make of that what you
will the fact is I was never arrested I
was never charged with the crime and I
won the only legal proceeding that took
place without my side of the story even
being heard uh and most importantly as
I've said from day one I never sexually
assaulted Lindsey Hill or anyone else
for that matter so I sued her which
prompted her to counter sue me quite
frankly regardless of the outcome in
court I've paid significantly more in
legal fees than lindsy Hill could ever
pay me in her entire life and I knew
that would be the case going in but the
lawsuit was never about the money for me
it was the only way for me to obtain
critical information to clear my name uh
the discovery process in that lawsuit
recently concluded at which point uh
lindsy Hill's legal team again came to
us with another proposal to resolve the
case uh this time however they weren't
seeking any money from me having
received uh much of the information that
had been hidden from us a small portion
of which I've referenced here um I was
willing to agree to the terms proposed
both parties would drop their respective
lawsuits and neither of us would pay
either side any money
um I also retained my right to speak
publicly about the case something I have
not been at Liberty to do since June of
2021 oh crazy as of today both lawsuits
have been settled now over the last two
years I've been forced to defend my
Integrity uh and my reputation in a very
public setting but hopefully this is the
last time I have to do so as I'd prefer
to just remain focused on doing my job
uh winning baseball games and
entertaining fans around the world so
today I'm happy to be moving on with my
life good he lost his care yeah so
shamon dude he lost he was a star
pitcher on the LA Dodgers and they had
this information and they didn't want to
deal with the backlash they kicked him
off the team yeah so shame on them shame
on they get Su shame on the Dodgers
shame on every [__] Sports uh talking
head who went bad on him and shame on
everybody in the media [__] all you
pieces of [__] [__] all you guys and and
you know you destroy a guy's life you
don't believe in due process and if you
don't believe in due process you don't
believe in Freedom speech or anything
else that makes this country great so
[__] you a second time and I'm just so
glad that this [__] it's coming out now
believe all
women that monster scumbag should be in
jail for 20 years my my thing put her in
jail that's my problem if if there's no
recourse if there's no repercussion of
people making false claims this isn't
going to stop cuz what happened to her
nothing now is she going to get shamed
on social media sure is that enough no
needs go the minimum should be 3 years
in prison that's you took this man's
livelihood yeah but but Brenan again in
this day and age with social media you
can tell a story and this is a male
female thing it just is a woman can tell
a story a man makes a statement you'll
never win you you just you your
everything goes away point to all these
Brilliant Minds and the men with the
most money the most power the most
powerful people in the world are men
don't give a [__] out you want put it
the most powerful men at what point do
those movers and shakers go this isn't
right dude if any women can just come
out and ruin a man's livelihood his
reputation and there's no repercussions
this this can't be good cuz it's it's
ruining Society more and more women are
saying that I think I think actually men
can't win that I think women and they
are a lot of women are going what the
[__] is going on I have a husband I have
a father I the problem with this
the problem with this is she actually
hurts the the me too this stuff destroys
all credibility so now the next person
that comes out with a famous athlete or
Entertainer we're going to go we've seen
this when she might really have a case
so what she's she's not an ally for
women she's the exact opposite she's not
only hurting you guys she's hurting us
she's a monster she should be dealt with
with severe consequences Amber make a
[__] example of that her and Amber
Hood [__] those people man they're the
worst of the worst the wor they should
get 10 years in prison man yeah it's
awful what a terrible person she she
she's the exact problem with societ
sociopath man she actually go goes the
opposite to help women she's doing the
worst but so go back the principle of
due process the reason you have du
processes because there will always be
people men and women who are going to do
that there are bad people in the world
and if you have a system in society
where somebody can just tell a story
about you it's called the Salem Witch
Trials it goes back it's why we have
courts it's why you have to but we're
not learning either look at my my boy
Mata okay this young kid this girl's I
don't know this story sorry the punter
we had him
on San Diego State the number one punter
in the nation doesn't have a job right
now cuz a girl some made up a story and
got him kicked off the Buffalo Bills and
now we know for a fact that that's all
fake damage already done team's like ah
we just want to deal with it yeah Trevor
Bower his whole life he could sign with
the team right now and be the best
pitcher team's like yeah we don't want
to deal with negativity what but he did
nothing I think everybody should be
stepping up about this everybody should
be supporting I would buy his i' be the
first one in line to buy I want to hear
people apologize I want to know who went
bad on him I want to know who what what
what talking Fox I mean I mean even even
dog Sten A Smith did the Dodgers should
[__] suck him off dude and again I
bet he doesn't sue the Dodgers because
he wants to play ball well they better
give him a job because if they don't
think he should everybody W they won't
that's the world we live in they won't
they go hey ma'am we messed up my bet
can I play nah no we don't want that
[__] yeah but you you made them that's
where that's where corporate money needs
to step up too like how long you going
to do this if you you don't believe in D
or anything so you just give all the
power if I'm the Padres I'm signing
Trevor Boward I'm putting him at the
face of our franchise principal and you
don't think that guy has a feather up
his ass to [__] slang some fast balls
oh my God when he comes back to the
league which I do hopefully he gets back
we should get him on the podc good
[__] luck yeah I was a huge fan of
his before all this then after again you
look at the headlines like geez this is
bad and now you see this like holy this
poor guy and you got all these people
going B on him just without knowing any
of the facts just going bad on him he's
my favorite player now he should be
because we all in America we all root
for the underdog well we root for a
comeback story there's not a bigger
comeback story than this talented
talented man who won the Sai Young and
some took it all from just for
money how the Padres the Tampa Bay how
somebody do sign this Elite Talent is
insane scumbags
anyway what else you got that's we
should probably end it on that let's end
it on that guys I'll tase you right now
I'm so Fu go for it do it
again nah nah I'll see you this weekend
Greensboro North Carolina Friday
Saturday let's go Comedy Zone then I got
oh by the way I just added uh um the
Chicago improv October 27 and 28 so come
there in shur you just but that's 50
miles away so it's all good all right
all right NRA Falls November 4th and 5th
two shows both almost sold out [__]
Falls is Casino I've never been out
there I'll probably check out the Falls
November 4th and 5th Chicago I'll be in
Chicago downtown Chicago December 8th
and 9th two shows Friday two shows
Saturday bunch other dates coming up
tickets at thi boy.com or or uh was it t
or F
az.com uh we're just waiting people keep
asking about this gang Fest episode I
reached out to them hopefully have it
soon so we going post it for you guys so
you can see it um the car content I'm
supposed to pick up my car next week it
should be done uh it's going to be dope
we're launch a new show around it and I
got a crazy idea that I think is going
be really dope around the whole car mod
scene so that's going to be dope can I
get involved in that absolutely not okay
absolutely I'm a car guy now all right
Trevor bar let me know if you want me to
hook your car up all right guys love you
we're out